في تفاعلكم دائما بنناقش معكم يعني الامور
اللي شغلاكم واللي حديث الساعه واليوم
لاحظنا شيء مسيطر على كل العناوين خليني
اقرا لكم بعضهم موجه حر شديده تضرب
الولايات المتحده واكثر من 50 مليون
امريكي سيتعرض لموجد حر هذا الاسبوع عام
2022 اكثر الاعوام حرا في سوريا وفي
سويسرا عفوا موجود حر شديده تجتاح اسبانيا
الفاو تحذر من اثار الشد موجد حر تجتاح
اهوار العراق من اربعين عاما اكثر من 60
الف حاله وفاه في اوروبا قد تكون ناجمه عن
الحر في صيف 20 22
انخفاض هائل في مستويات الجليد بالقطب
الجنوبي
كل العناوين اللي سمعتوها الان هذه من
اخبار اليوم يعني متخيلين انه صار لنا
سنين بنسمع طبعا عن الاحتباس الحراري
ودرجه الحراره اللي بتزيد لكن هذا الكم من
الاخبار في يوم واحد ايش اللي جالس يصير
لا وفوق كل هذا وفي نفس اليوم كمان اعلنت
منظمه الارصاد الجويه العالميه التابعه
للامم المتحده اعلنت ان الاسبوع الماضي هو
الاسبوع هو الاسبوع الاكثر حرا على
الاطلاق مع درجات حراره مو مسبوقه على سطح
البحر وانخفاض قياسي في الجديد البحري
بالقطب الجنوبي
يعني الاحتباس الحراري والتغير المناخي
موضوع الساعه في العالم السنوات الماضيه
الان ايش اللي جالس يصير في شيء جديد يفسر
هذا الكم الهائل من الاخبار عن ارتفاع
درجات الحراره واحنا كناس عاديين مو
مختصين مناخ او ارصاد يعني ممكن نفهم من
هذه الاخبار هل المفروض نقلت خلونا نسال
مختص معنا جمال الموسى مستشار مركز طقس
العرب اهلا فيك معنا استاذ جمال هل اللي
بيصير هذا فعلا موضوع تصاعدي انه كل سنه
عن سنه فعلا نحن بنكون هذا الصيف اكثر
حراره من اللي قبله وهكذا وهكذا
مساء الخير لحضرتك ومساء الخير لجميع
مشاهدينا فعلا هي بدات درجات الحراره
بالارتفاع في هناك دور للنشاط البشري دور
لاستخدام الوقود الاحفوري بسبب انبعاث
الغازات الدفيئه اللي هي اهمها ثاني اكسيد
الكربون وغاز الميثان واكسيد النيتروز هذه
ازدادت كمياتها في الغلاف الجوي وايضا زاد
تركيزها ادت الى ارتفاع درجات الحراره
الان هذه الانبعاثات في تزايد مستمر درجات
الحراره في تسارع مستمر ايضا
وبالتالي ينتج عنها تغيرات مناخيه
والتغيرات المناخيه طبعا ينتج عنها انماط
طقس متطرفه منها الموجات الحاره الموجات
الغضاريه امطار غزيره فيضانات
الان وايضا ممكن موجات بارده احيانا بس
الان لما نشوف هذا الكم من العناوين يعني
بنحس انه خلص العالم حينتهي نحن يعني فعلا
يعني ظاهره جديده وكاننا على صفيح ساخن
خلاص النهايه قربت يعني
المهم انه اخر سبع سنوات من 2015 وحتى
نهايه عام 2022 كانت هي السنوات الادفى
حسب تقارير منظمه الارصاد الجويه العالميه
والخبراء في المناخ وفي الارصاد الجويه
ادفا سنه كانت وسجلت تقريبا هي 2016 عبر
التاريخ لانه كانت فيها ظاهره النينو لكن
فيما بعد اللي هي عام 2022
والسنوات اللي قبلها باستثناء 2016 كانت
اعلى لكن اقل من 2016 ليش لانه كانت ظاهره
النينا ما هي ظاهره النينو ظاهره النينو
هي تغيير في توزيع درجات الحراره في
المناطق الاستوائيه في المحيط الهادي
العام الماضي كانت ظاهره اللامينا
والسنتين او الثلاثه يعني من عام 2016
يعني منذ سبع سنين لم تاتي ظاهره النين
ظاهره النينو بتصير المياه في شرق المحيط
الهادي وفي وسطه تصبح ادفا وفي غرب تصبح
ابرد لكن عكسها بيكون الا نينا هاي ظاهره
النينو الها تاثير على المناخ بحيث تسبب
ارتفاع في درجات الحراره انا من جانب هذا
اذا التقت مع النشاط البشري وزياده انبعاث
الغازات الدفيئه وزياده تسارع درجات
الحراره
فهذا يؤدي الى الحديث المستمر هذا بس هذا
الحديث الحديث المستمر هذا انه كل سنه
اكثر بتزيد الحراره يعني حديث في مبالغه
انت بتقول انه سنه 2016 هي كانت الاحر
فعليا بسبب عده عوامل
صاحيه اهمها كانت ظاهره النينو الان في
الان في تقريبا اربعه سبعه من هذا الشهر
اعلنت منظمه الارصاد الجويه العالميه
اعلنت انه ايضا هناك تعود ظاهره احوال
اللينو تظهر على الكره الارضيه مره اخرى
وبكون تاثيراتها واضحه وهذا معناه انه لفت
حكومات العالم لفت شعوب العالم الى ان
هناك يجب الانظار المبكر في هذه الحاله
انه هناك في ارتفاع محتمل
استاذ جمال يعني هو الوضع
لا يحتمل اكثر من كده يعني استغفر الله
العظيم بس درجات الحراره يعني الان واحنا
لسه حتى ما دخلنا في اوغست يعني الحر مو
طبيعي الصراحه يعني ففي اكثر من كده جاي
يعني حنوصل كم
صحيح يعني تصوري مو بريطانيا العام الماضي
في 2022 موجه الحر لاصابتها والسنه اللي
قبلها 2021 كندا كانت معدل درجات الحراره
في لندن بحدود 21 العظمى العام وصلت 45
يعني حتى في بريطانيا ما كانوش يستخدموا
المكيفات وايضا اثرت على سكك الحديد اثرت
على المطارات اذا ايضا نتوقع وتتوقع منظمه
الارصاد الجويه العالميه ان تسجل درجات
الحراره في السنوات الخمس القادمه ارقام
قياسيه جديده وايضا تتوقع في انه من عام
2023 وحتى عام 2027 راح يكون في هناك
ارتفاع كبير في درجات الحراره وعلى الاقل
سنه واحده من سنوات الخمس القادم رائحه
تقريبا
تتجاوز حاجز سنه 2016 وتكون ادفا من حاجز
احر وبكثير انت قصدك حر حر حر حر قصدك
كلمه ادفا
لا تعبر عن الوضع اللي نحن فيه طيب الله
يبشرك بالخير استاذ جمال يعني نحن اسوا من
حيث الحراره
وصلت رسالتك جرحك وصل شكرا
ايضا في سته وستين في الميه بتقول منظمه
الارصاد الجويه العالميه انه قد تتجاوز
درجه الحراره في السنوات الخمس القادمه
الزياده في معدلات درجات الحراره على
الاقل درجه ونص وهذا الحد اللي وضعه مؤتمر
باريس للمناخ عام 2015 بحيث ان لا تتجاوز
الزياده في درجه الحراره عن درجه ونصف حتى
نتجنب كثير من المصاعب وكثير من انماط
الطقس المتطرفه الكثير من انماط الطقس
المتطرفه والمزعجه والمضطرب اللي تؤثر على
صحه الانسان على حياته على السياحه على
الاقتصاد على البيئه وعلى يعني في المقدمه
انتم حكيتوا كيف الانهار الجليديه
تنصهر وتذوب وايضا موجات الحار وموجات
الفيضانات هاي كلها انها تكلفه ماليه يعني
سنويا العام الماضي تقريبا
اقتربت الخسائر الاقتصاديه بسبب التغيرات
المناخيه وبسبب انماط الطقس المتطرفه
تجاوزت ال300 مليار دولار في العالم اذا
العالم مقبل اذا لم يضع حد للانبعاثات
الغازات الدفيئه ولم يضع حد لزياده في
درجات الحراره فنحن مقبلين فعلا على كوارث
اكثر وهذا ما توقعته
بعد اللي قلته انت يا استاذ جمال نحن في
طريقنا الى الهاويه فعلا على العموم يعني
هذا ملف طبعا التغير المناخي والاحتباس
الحراري وكل هذه الامور ملف مهم جدا يعني
والحكومات العالم كلها اصبحت يعني تقريبا
كلها داخله فيه وبتناقش فيه بكل جديه
وبتحاول تلاقي حلول على العموم بنشكرك على
هذه المعلومات حتى وان كانت يعني معلومات
يعني شويه محبطه بس شكرا لك كان معنا جمال
الموسى مستشار مركز طقس العرب